One of the promises I made when I started
this show was I would personally acknowledge
legitimate criticism when it's thrown my way.
This acknowledgment is one of the reasons
I do live Q&A's right here on YouTube, as
well as on Twitter, Facebook, and even when
people come up to me on the street.
Not only do I genuinely like hearing from
you directly, but I think it's also important
to hear the bad feedback right along with
the good.
Note I said legit criticism, and not hysterical
troll criticism.
For example, I'm happy to hear from people
who want me to ask questions differently,
or to have more aggressive follow ups or to
find alternative guests, or anything along
those lines.
Those qualify as legit criticism whether or
not I agree.
The people who just tell me that I'm a straight
white supremcaist neo nazi alt right racist,
well let's just say I'm less likely to engage
with you.
The battle of ideas is far more interesting
to me than the battle to be first to sarcastically
respond to a tweet.
One criticism I hear occasionally is I'm actually
not a liberal, and I'm really a secret conservative.
Or, sometimes they'll say I'm the only thing
worse than a conservative: a dreaded right
winger.
Now it is true, I've been saying for months
that defending my liberal principles, is now
a conservative position.
But am I still a liberal?
Do I still believe in any of thing things
that people on the left believe?
Since we have so many new subscribers around
here I thought I'd lay out some of my liberal
cred for you, in case you missed it...
I'm so for gay marriage, I even married a
guy!
I'm pro-choice, I'm against the death penalty,
I'm for a social safety net.
I'm for a strong public education system,
I'm for legalizing marijuana, I'm for reforming
our prison system, and I'm against unnecessary
wars and nation building.
There's other stuff too, but I think I've
made my point.
Beyond any of those specific issues though,
I'm for true tolerance of opinion and thought.
My liberalism is one of a live and let live
attitude.
This is where I diverge from the modern left.
I see virtually no diversity of thought or
tolerance of other opinions on the Left of
today, just constant smearing and slandering
of all intellectual opponents.
Take a step back for a moment and think about
your friends on the Left.
Are they tolerant of people who aren't for
gay marriage, or of people who are pro choice?
These used to be political differences, now
they are somehow a referendum on what type
of person you are, and whether you can be
in someone's life.
I wish this intolerance was an isolated case,
but not only have I seen this type of intolerance
first hand, but I hear it from you guys every
single day.
I get emails about marriages breaking up,
life long friends no longer talking to each
other and people afraid to say what they think
politically because of repercussions it will
have at work.
And by the way, now I'll reverse that.
Do you know people on the right who are tolerant
of people who are for gay marriage and who
are pro life?
I actually do, plenty of them, including people
who I've had on this show.
When there is a disagreement, I see way more
people on the right, conservatives or libertarians,
more often willing to agree to disagree attitude
rather than defriending or smearing?
Could the right be better?
Are there real bigots on the right?
Absolutely.
Are there real racists on the right?
Without question, but by and large these aren't
the voices from the mainstream right anymore.
Let's not forget, even Donald Trump got a
standing ovation at the Republican National
Convention when he talked about protecting
LGBTQ rights.
Of course all this said, doesn't mean things
are all right with the right right now.
Just in the last few weeks Tomi Lahren was
let go by The Blaze after she came out as
being pro-choice Or at the very least giving
a conservative explanation for abortion by
saying the government should stay out of a
women's private life.
I actually agree with her rationalization
here and know that position upsets a lot of
Conservatives.
The immediate reaction to her comments and
her subsequent firing strike me as the intolerance
we're used to seeing from the Left these days,
not the Right.
And for the record, I'd I've invited Tomi
on the show, and Glenn Beck back on the show
to discuss what went down between them.
I happen to like them both and we all have
views that are inconsistent with our broader
ideologies.
We're not not robots yet, we're still human.
Oh, and yes, by the way it is Glenn's right
as a private businessman to hire and fire
people as he sees fit, even if I don't agree
with the reason why he did it.
Another area which I don't fit into the traditional
political box is gun control.
I absolutely believe in the 2nd amendment
and obviously also believe that a healthy
distrust of the government is an important
part of being American.
Democrats often make it sounds like Republicans
want every American wandering the streets
with a weapon like we're in the wild west
and Republicans often make it sound like every
Democrat wants to take away their right to
self defense.
As for me, I believe we have the right to
bare arms but also have to keep weapons out
of the hands of the wrong people, and perhaps
even more importantly, have a discussion about
mental health, which usually has more to do
with these shootings than just the weapon
itself.
As always.
I'll keep talking about free speech, free
expression, and the rights of the individual
which I believe to be the most important facet
of a truly free society.
Whether that makes me a Libtard or a Cuckservative
or a right wing maniac is for the commenters
to decide.